>> Have you ever wanted to improve your community?
Or help your local government become more
connected?
With the power of the Google places API you
can.
>> PARSONS: Hi, I'm Ed Parsons, Google Geospatial
Technologist.
And I'm pleased to announce the Google Places
API developed challenge.
We're encouraging developers around the world
to use the power of the Places API combined
with municipal data set to create the next
generation of cool and critical applications
that will address some of the challenges faced
by our communities.
>> We're inviting developers, designer, and
other tech savvy individuals, to enter our
Google Places API developer challenge.
And build an app to make something better.
>> NATH: For cities like San Francisco, the
Google Places API challenge is a tremendous
opportunity to work with talented developers.
Those community assets can be things like
shelters, they can be places like where the
nearest post office is or places where there's
wreck centers, parks.
Using Google Places API is a great way to
really use the power of the web to extend
the assets that we have to our--to our community.
>> STERNE: We're always looking for new ways
that developers can use data and integrate
with platforms and API such as Google Places
API to help people get more out of New York
City.
And this could be anything from finding the
location of Green Market and Farmer's Market
that are close to where you live, to being
able to enjoy more public art that's throughout
the city of this place.
>> COLLINGE: London's greatest data challenge
I think still has be around transport.
I'm really looking forward to this next stage
in opening up data to those who want to come
in and enjoy it, extract value from it and
make London a better place to live as a result
of that.
So thank you to Google for doing so.
>> TOLVA: There's so much of our data, the
vast majority of it is spatial, it's place
based.
What I would love to see is a truly holistic
multi-modal, sort of transportation or how
do I get from point A to point B and what
are all my options.
You know, using the Google Places API, you
could note things like the status of street
being clean and so inaccessible.
Something that's real time, that's hyper local
to where you are, but is aware of the status
of all the places and spaces that you plan
to go.
>> PARSONS: Now that you've heard from some
of the cities working with us on the Places
API developer challenge.
I hope you feel inspired to use the Places
API.
Check out the data sets we linked to from
the challenge website and start building the
[INDISTINCT] spatial applications.
That will address an interesting digital challenge
in an innovative way.
Thanks for your participation, and we can't
wait to see you around.
>> Enter now at developers.google.com/challenge.